[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and the next step
is mike sugarman um
mike's the title of mike's thesis is
playing it by ear
improvisation and music live streaming
during covid19 and i'm going to turn it
back over to tl
great thanks i'm really excited so
unlike diego who i first met
in class uh really i i got to meet mike
and i've come to know him and really
appreciate his work
because of his thesis work and it's i'm
really excited for you all to hear it um
as someone myself who's done stuff in
live streaming i have learned so much
from mike
and i love how he has just extended
and kind of uh brought some new insights
into this space and can i just say too i
just
have to give huge high fives not just to
diego and mike but to all of the thesis
students for
just doing this amidst the pandemic i
mean of course i saw diego and mike
deal with it in a very up-close way but
i think they've
they've both and all of you have done a
tremendous job uh dealing
dealing with this so and and mike's
mike's topic as you will see is just
talk about seizing seizing the moment so
really looking forward to hearing like
share this haul with you
great can everyone see that yeah
getting nods from william okay tl thank
you for a
uh really thoughtful introduction and
thank you everyone who has been watching
these presentations all day
and is sticking around um
so today i will be presenting my thesis
playing it by ear improvisation and
music live streaming during code 19.
um i want to start with a quote um
our ticket is to get ourselves together
as a body
they got this thing set up in a certain
way but can't control us
because we have the music and that's
what they're after
now if that's not a good reason for
organizing i don't know what it is
muhal richard abrams said this on may
29th
1965 at an early meeting of what would
become
the association for the advancement of
creative musicians
this quote comes from georgie lewis's
book a power
stronger than itself the definitive
history of the long-running
internationally influential free jazz
organization
aacm the context here is
economic collapse black people on the
south side of chicago were bearing the
brunt of de-industrialization
and the city government disinvesting in
their communities leaving those black
communities to crumble
jazz clubs there were vanishing in the
mid 60s and ones that still operated
were interested in
outmoded versions of the genre today
like abrams i will be talking about
music about control
about the disenfranchisement of some
people because of their bodies
about what happens when people organize
in a body
and much like abrams i will be talking
about improvising
in crisis his are words from over 50
years ago
but they might not stand out of place
for a musician to say them today
i am speaking to you from a room where i
have spent
much of the last year in a room where i
conducted all of the interviews for this
project
where i did most of the writing where i
play music in video games unwind
where i have felt at times stir crazy
depressed resigned to make the most of
this 90 square foot office
given how much of the past year i've
spent sitting in this chair
it's easy to forget how much has
actually happened in that time
and how truly strange it was at the
beginning
today i present to you my research on
improvised music live streaming
something that developed rapidly and
comprehensively when kovit
rapidly and comprehensively changed our
lives
i would like to start this talk by
taking us back to the beginning of the
pandemic in march of 2020
when everything was fresh and scary and
terribly confusing
i called this thesis playing it by ear
since
that's what we were all doing in those
early days trying to improvise a new way
of life
be those small things like stocking up
at the supermarket to minimize scripts
to monumentally difficult tasks like
learning how to juggle child care and a
new work from home lifestyle
in my life suddenly grad school went
remote
my professors had to improvise classes
that would work over
zoom and i had to improvise completing
coursework
and starting this thesis without access
to a library where
any of the spaces i relied on to get out
of the house
and into the zone i have spent
all of my adult life participating in
local music scenes as
a musician organizer journalist
and most importantly as a fan it has
been devastating
to live the past year without access to
the friends and inspiration i get from
chosen properties but
right at the outset of the pandemic
people started broadcasting musical
performance on the live stream platform
twitch there was a great massive live
streams that were happening quickly
and they were a real lifeline not just
for
myself and my friends but for musicians
and nightlife workers who were supported
by mutually efforts propped up
before any talk of stimulus checks or
expanded unemployment were even
whispered
not only were all of these livestreams
welcome but they were often fun
you could see ads who never tore through
your city while chatting with your
friends
all in your absolutely mostly in
sweatpants the thing about
live streams is the vibes are always
hiding it was a nice contrast to
well everything else the question
animating this thesis was
how did this widespread music livestream
practice
spread so quickly at the beginning of
the pandemic and how did things change
during the uprising last spring and
summer spurred by george
floyd's murder what i learned what i
argued is that music communities created
a structure
through improvisation working to adapt
existing community
and organizing structures they
improvised a new virtual way of doing
things they used to do offline
this works because improvisation needs
structure and they had old structures
from in-person scenes
yet it also reflects a wider scale lack
of structure
where they have to scramble to put
together a new way of life
and look after their own when the bottom
fell out at the beginning of the
pandemic
when that structure exists it can foster
wild creativity and create
safety for bodies who bear the brunt of
intolerance and structural violence
yet when that structure to support
improvisation
does not exist precarity remains
putting vulnerable people in danger
echoing muhal richard abrams
organization structure that's what
creates the conditions for people
improvising to thrive
to make this point i will be talking
about three things platforms
improvisation and community in that
platform section
i will talk about twitch a live sharing
platform owned by
amazon where performers broadcast in
real time
and the audience converses with each
other in the chat and often donates
money
as my advisor on this project t.l taylor
chronicles in her book watch me play
twitch has traditionally been used to
broadcast people playing video games
there are some really important really
interesting and important things to
understand
about what happens when people broadcast
musical performance instead
in the following section on
improvisation i show how
improvisation is not just a style of
musical performance but a social thing
that will help us understand the moment
when these livestream practices
pivoted from fundraising for mutual aid
efforts
for local community to fundraising for
bail funds and specific
black community members that pivot
begs the discussion about community
which will be the final section of this
talk
what is community who is part of a given
community
who is excluded and how are they
excluded
what happens to improvising communities
when they have external structure
and what happens when they do not but
before all this let me give you a better
idea of how i conducted my research
my study examined a diverse range of
people and events
i observed dozens of live streams and
interviewed 11 participants
those participants range in age from
their mid-20s to early 40s
and span white people and people of
color straight and queer people
and both cisgender and transfer i should
clarify to help you follow along during
this presentation
that i see dynamized the people and
programs involved with the interview
portion of the study and use the real
names of people and programs that i
observed
but did not interview so the people i
interviewed were involved with a wide
range of events
there were long-running parties put
together in the video game minecraft
that were re-broadcast on twitch to
reach a broader audience
there were small scale experimental
music and dj streams that were
intended as gathering places for
geographically specific scenes and
groups of friends physically isolated
from one another
there was a nightly experimental music
and jazz series booked by a national
coalition of venues and organizers which
i referred to several times in this talk
as
jazz on the grill improvisatory music
relies on feedback the performer
receives be that from on stage
collaborators or from the audience
all of the music i studied here was
therefore improvisatory music
perhaps we all have some idea of how
this works in the jazz combo
but the same dynamic applies to djs2 who
often choose records depending on their
response from the room
and how they want to guide the party
these music scenes orbit around the
so-called
underground organizing themselves in
propository diy
practices developed in the punk and rave
scenes of the 1980s and 1990s
and therefore these communities tend to
exist outside of the commercial live
music industry
plenty of live streaming came from that
commercial live music industry during
the pandemic
ranging from the popular versus series
featuring hip hop and r b stars on
instagram live
to ticketed concerts on proprietary
platforms
but i focus on twitch because that is
where music live streaming was most
prolific
thanks in large part to the scenes and
communities that adopted the platform as
a substitute
for their in-person events in my
research
i was jotting down notes and obsessively
collecting visual material
advertising these events such as the
flyers that you see here
often shared on social media part of
what i learned during the study
came from organizing live streams on my
own website but most came from
participating in others
sometimes i participated in chats and
sometimes
like i imagined so many on the other
side of the screen
i just sat back in the days and let the
music watch over me
since twitch is the key platform in my
study we need to understand how the
platform influenced what i studied
to encounter twitch let's encounter
twitch
right now the same way you might
encounter it if you logged on for a live
stream
this screenshot comes courtesy of our
department's very own philip tan who has
been djing on twitch regularly for over
a year now
i actually invited philip to watch this
talk but he
is live on twitch right at this moment
as you can see twitch is a pretty
crowded interface but there are a few
key elements
live video takes up most of the space on
the screen
and you'll see some overlays on the
video here
philip is using a second camera to show
the records he's playing
and has added a personalized logo and
information about where to follow
him on social media some streams will
overlay a venmo handle
where audience members can donate or
animated gifts to make things more
playful
philip like so many live streamers is
using software called obs
short for open broadcasting studio to
compile the visuals for a stream
combine the audio from his turntables
with the video from his cameras
and broadcast that all to twitch on the
left
this is what philip sees when he
broadcasts on the right
what you see when watching it then
all the way to the right of this diagram
you will see the live chat
this is where audience members hype up
the performer and talk to each other
communicating in both text and emoji
behind the scenes there is a human
moderator moderating the chat
as well as software algorithm
sorry algorithmic software that
automatically filters out
offensive language and hate speech
while there are just a handful of
important elements for its strengths and
platform
twitch was often narrativized to me
during interviews
as this intricate weave of technical
processes and technologies
and those were usually narratives about
things going terribly wrong
when i interviewed organizers of jazz on
thrill
they described their first ever stream
to me initially broadcast on youtube
live
early on the night the stream
arbitrarily stopped during a dj set
and those behind the scenes could only
guess why
one organizer of the series alvin foster
recounted that the team figured youtube
recognized copyright material which he
told me
quote tipped off the channel or
something like that could have been that
we never figured out though
it could have also been trolls reporting
you can click report
a live stream could just get shut down
by one report
we don't know the organizers of jazz on
the grill decided to create a twitch
account in the middle of that concert
and they were able to move the
performers in the audience to twitch and
run the rest of that stream without any
issues with copyright or trolls
but that was not the last of the
technical issues
later in the stream one solo
instrumental improviser
struggled to figure out how to get her
audio to broadcast through
obs this anecdote
shows how live streaming music is in
part a practice that relies on several
technologies working
shall we say in concert each of which
can bring their own technical issues
television broadcast broadband networks
digital signal processing algorithmic
rule enforcement
just to name a few but saying that live
streaming is
just technologies in concert is only
half the story
i argue that live streaming fuses
communication
practices with communication
technologies
to understand how twitch works as a
concert space we should get a detailed
understanding of exactly what
communication practices
and communication technologies are at
play both
online and offline i will illustrate
this with twitch
but i assure you that none of these are
specific to in person or virtual space
new operators the invitation the
organizer sends to the performer and the
logistical juggling of sorting out the
schedule
the rapport between the performer and
the audience the conversation among the
audience
the exchange of money between audience
and organizer
and then between the organizer and the
performer not to mention
the communication between nodes of the
dispersed network
of servers and computers maybe
that last part sounds specific to a
virtual concert
but keep in mind that much event
promotion for in-person shows
relies on social media platforms
all of that communication and technology
skills together
and contributes to what we might call a
vibe
bruno le tour would invite us to think
of the technologies in those
relationships
as agents as actors albeit non-human
ones
he imagines a co-constitutive
relationship
between humans and non-human actors
could we consider music one of these
non-humans too
consider one origin story music live
streaming told me by arlo bohannon
a long time music live streamer who
helped organize
the club chris sandwich parties in the
video game minecraft
which ran for several years prior to the
pandemic
arlo has been involved with live
streaming since the mid-2000s
and described what the technical
landscape looked like in the early
audio only days before platforms
he had to use shoutcast servers to
broadcast audio
and irc chats for live discussion among
the audience
so the discorders among the audience was
mediated
and circumscribed by the specific
assortment of
non-humans or technologies used to make
that stream work
yes it took a lot of labor to run a live
stream
in the days before twitch but it also
takes a lot of labor now
i learned this when i spent well
over an hour on the phone with a
performer i booked for one of my own
live stream concerts
i walked him through some arduous
troubleshooting process so he could
successfully broadcast his field
recordings to twitch
i experienced a peculiar kind of
intimacy with the performer
clicking to the same menus remotely
trying to put myself in his shoes to
debug his system
sometimes you really feel just how much
interpersonal human relationships
undergird what we otherwise think of as
media and technological phenomena
and of course we have bizarrely intimate
encounters with faceless
powerful corporations too again
twitch is owned by amazon amazon
also owns and operates several different
marketplaces
where people sell things that were not
produced by amazon
so granola and cheese have whole foods
gig labor a mechanical turk and on its
own namesake market
fashion accessories innovative hygienic
equipment
and fine literature should we understand
twitch as yet another marketplace that
amazon
operates and if so what is it selling
perhaps the product is what tl taylor
calls
transformative play the alchemical media
object of broadcasters creativity and
labor
the audience's participation and in the
case of both video games and dj music
intellectual property whose rebroadcast
rights belongs to
no one involved in exchange for offering
customers that transformative play
twitch gets advertising revenue and a
cut of all paid subscriptions to
channels on the platform
twitch in exchange provided structure
that improvisers could adapt to so on
that note
let's talk about improvisation on twitch
the improvising performer can't perceive
the same type of feedback that they do
during in-person shows
this is a conundrum since their art form
relies on cues from collaborators and
reactions
in the audience i'll return to this
slide from earlier in the presentation
uh this is a still from a performance by
woody an experimental dance music
producer based in pittsburgh
let's take woody's point of view you can
tell by the camera angle
that they are broadcasting using the
camera on their mobile phone perhaps
prop
up against the wall you can see in the
bottom right hand corner of that live
video
that they are using their laptop to dj
and likely
the djing software fills that laptop's
entire screen
therefore woody in all likelihood cannot
see the chat
where the crowd is effusive unable to
receive that feedback from the audience
woody perhaps does not feel like the set
is much different than just
practicing at home during interviews i
would regularly ask musicians
what this experience is like for them
reactions random
on one hand there was the jazz on the
grill organizer elvin
himself an experimental musician and
jazz drummer
he found the experience of playing a
solo synthesizer set on live stream
lonely and demoralizing especially when
compared to a set he played in a duo
with a close friend a few weeks earlier
on the other hand there was sun tate a
dj who developed a sense of their
relationship with a remote audience
sun understood that there are unique
responsibilities that a dj has when
playing to that audience
and puts it puts together sets based on
what those individuals listening
environments and mental states
might be like in isolation i view these
two
responses as basically opposite ends of
the spectrum
yep they both reflect the ways that
musicians are entangled
in social relations the sociologist of
music
and improvising musician georgina bourne
provides a useful framework for
understanding those entanglements
which she refers to as four planes of
social mediation
in music let me illustrate it using a
photograph from 1980
of a band georgina georgina-born
play-doh the feminist
improvising group in the first plane
music mediates for relationships between
musicians playing together
in the second music mediates the
interaction between musician and
audience electing to form an ad hoc
community attending that concert and the
third plane
music mediates the musician's
interaction with broader social
relations like race or
class in this case the feminist
improvising group
a group of gay women was often
confronting patriarchy and
heteronormativity with their music
in the fourth plane music mediates the
institutional context
for their performance such as if they
are performing in a state-sponsored
jazz space or if they are performing in
a grungy punk squad
these planes do not simply disappear
because music goes virtual on twitch
take the case of the biosphere 3 series
that i studied
whose organizers are a queer married
couple that both each day on the stream
when i asked them what it was like djing
without an audience present
izzy expressed the freedom he enjoyed of
being able to have access to
his entire record collection and try
anything
without having to worry about playing to
the room but kimya
expressed missing the rapport with the
supportive audience that
empowered her to take risks kimya
described to me how her ideal setting
was the camping festival in washington
state
called gays hate techno where a large
group of queer people
gather to enjoy music and celebrate each
other's company
and how djing on the live stream could
never replace the thrilling dynamic of
playing in that context
and even though the biosphere 3
organizers felt physically separated
from their familiar social mediations
they still developed new ones when the
protests
spurred by george floyd's murder broke
out they found ways to utilize
those second plane elective community
mediations to make sense of the larger
larger cultural forces they were
navigating suddenly
fundraising on their streams shifted to
supporting black trans
friends who were in financial need
during coveted indeeds unemployment
and they made the decision to continue
to run their streams as a way of
providing support for friends who were
participating in the racial justice
protests
in these instances we can see examples
of structure being propped up during
improvisation
that facilitates improvisation in
kimia's example
she feels that the structure of a
festival for queer techno lovers
supports her exploration and empowers
her to take risks while
improvising yet clearly the practice of
live streaming on twitch gave both her
and izzy a structure to support
their friends and community members when
a new crisis emerged
a few months into the pandemic so
let's return to new hall return abrams
both izzy and cameo are describing
exactly what abrams was talking about in
1965
musicians need solidarity and structure
to improvise successfully
i believe there's a flip side to this
that a lack of structure makes
improvisation
fundamentally risky i have been using
the word community a lot
sometimes to refer to community members
sometimes to refer to
a music community sometimes to refer to
a kind of community ethic
one question that emerged both in my own
study and in music at large during this
early pandemic period
was the question of what exactly is
community
and who is considered part of it in
terms of music
one way to understand community is the
way that georgina boren suggests in her
four planes of mediation
it is the people who elect to gather
around a certain kind of music or a
concert
yet that paradigm might not be full
enough
let's consider george floyd
shortly after his murder various music
publications
and users on twitter began circulating
the revelation
that george floyd wrapped as big floyd
in houston's fertile turn of the
millennium hip-hop scene
even making an album with one of the
city's most storied and beloved
producers
dj's crew the music team realized that
george floyd was one of us what people
didn't really talk about though was that
george floyd also worked as a security
guard
at latin nightclubs minneapolis that
often hosted techno parties
during my interview with the dj sun tate
we talked
a lot about the struggles black people
experienced in the dance music community
so when sun mentioned that they
sometimes work as a security guard at
techno shows
i asked how they felt about this
biographical parallel
they responded so you have the situation
where you got this person who was doing
security advancements at parties
but is anybody looping that back around
in the community to make sure that the
people that are protecting you
are protected themselves and then in
that case
if you're just using that to guard your
party but nobody's looking out for that
even though we're supposed to be this
universal
loving dance music scene that's
inclusive
are we really doing them
let's return to this four planes diagram
from earlier but modify it
what might it look like as something
with walls as something with a door
here the musicians audience and
institution
are inside you can picture someone
standing at the door
checking ids keeping the peace both
outside and
in from the outside what we're left with
is those broader social relations i will
keep this slide up as we consider
how communities and individuals make
decisions about who is
outside and who is inside so
let's return one last time to jazz on
the grill
that stream actually grew up grew out of
an in-person series called plateaus
at a midwestern nonprofit art space a
donor and regular member of that space
developed mobility issues and could no
longer attend shows there
so organizers of plateaus started live
streaming that show every week
for the express purpose of giving that
one community member access
because those organizers had experience
with live streaming
they were able to so quickly get the
jazz on the grill series off the ground
on twitch
when the pandemic started yet
improvising and adapting
does not necessarily equate to creating
spaces for
all who may want to participate one
night on jazz on the grill
a performer used a video effect that
resembled a strobe light
an audience member going by the username
gray alien
expressed concern about the strobing
given their sensitivity as an epileptic
another audience member discounted the
concern writing in the chat
this is noise music it's dangerous
great aliens said they were disappointed
to hear that kind of dismissal
since that exact cavalier attitude tends
to keep them away from in-person shows
where organizers often ignore that
strobe lights could pose a danger
live streams grey alien explained were
safer precisely because they themselves
had control over the environment and
then turned their risks
but seeing this attitude in the chat
still made them feel unwelcome
other participants in the chat quickly
came to grey alien side
denouncing the ableism on display and
expressing their support for grey alien
and shortly after that flippant member
apologized for his insensitivity
in some sense it was a matter of luck
that everything worked out as well as it
did
that the community shared the right set
of ethics and swiftly acted on them to
protect a vulnerable person
but what would have happened absent of
that response
this moment was a demonstration that
even though anyone with a fast enough
internet connection can access
any twitch stream they may not feel
welcomed by the community they find
there
these streams may be open to the public
and they may be community spaces but
that does
not mean that they are de facto safe for
all who want to participate
i asked us to consider the times that we
got lucky when spaces were safe
and the times that we did not consider
the case of the diy venue
ghost ship in oakland that claimed 36
lives when it caught fire in 2016.
in oakland a real estate crisis had
created a situation where it was
difficult
for a legal art community art spaces to
take hold
creating a vacuum for illegal spaces
like go ship to film
the venue's organizers were negligent
and operated the venue in a profoundly
hazardous reckless way when it burned
down it took human life
and much of the energy of the music
scene with it it is a sobering reminder
that improvisation
can create something surprisingly robust
and can support
people and communities in need but that
support is
only as secure as the structures that
the improvisation
occurs within i will end this talk by
asking that we consider
how we might build real structure for
improvisation
something in the vein of what we call
richard abrams and the association for
advancement of creative musicians
built a half century ago that continues
to this day
this is a picture of the aacm from a
50th anniversary performance a few years
ago
i hope that if i shown you a problem
today it's only because i'm showing you
the flip side
of something quite inspiring and
beautiful real support systems
often created by groups propped up alone
by a love of music and one another
these are imperfect support systems as
all are
so maybe you and i don't have good
answers for how we can get public arts
funding into our cities to support
nonprofit community spaces that provide
a safe place
for scenes to gather and thrive but
maybe we can walk we can walk away from
this talk today
looking around us to see how people
improvise
how they do it willingly and
passionately together
and what we might do to the world around
us to help those people
to help ourselves develop something
better and safer
where improvising is not just something
we do
in a frenzy when the bottom falls out
thank you
great thank you mike um we're open for
questions
[Music]
okay there's the oh ethan yes and then
there's also
a question that's come up in chat go
ahead ethan
thanks hey mike congratulations on the
presentation it's wonderful to
watch all these ideas um come together
in synthesis
um i i think that acknowledgment that
you know your
your thesis itself has been an
improvisation and that we're all
in the midst of that act of improvising
um is a really important
piece of context for all of this um
in this whole process i've been
challenging you to
um you know sort of identify more
clearly who it was that you were
studying what what were these specific
livestream practices
i think i finally get it in this
presentation and i
i think at the end of the day um
you're really reflecting more than
anything on improvisation
both in the musical stance and also in
the sense of constructing the the sort
of social and cultural structures
that allow people to come together on
these sort of four
planes um i i love
that this has sort of progressed from
sort of an analysis of
of how twitch was going to be used in
the space um through to these very
complicated conversations like what does
it mean
for george floyd to be one of us how are
we sort of constructing the space for
us who gets to be outside who gets to be
inside
um and i love this idea that um
improvisation can can lead to incredible
resilience but
but in a way that can also be
tremendously dangerous
um if left in the the sort of space of
things along the lines of ghost ship
i'm wondering you know as we find
ourselves sort of coming to
what may be a different phrase in the
pandemic
how do you see this process of
these online spaces and improvisation
with them changing do you think this is
going to remain
as we turn a corner and live performance
becomes
more possible do you think that in the
same way that jazz on the grill
sort of became an online space out of
necessity that that will end up staying
and do you have a sense for how
the sort of resilience and creativity
that's been expressed in these online
spaces
might come into play when we sort of
return to
what you might think of as the normal
precarity uh of being involved with the
business of making and sharing music
uh yeah so that's a bunch of big
questions and i think i can probably
also answer
doug kaplan's question in the chat while
getting at that um
well i'll start with the simple one
where is this going to go i mean i think
that
you know i just want to clarify and make
it very clear i really studied like
three three and a half months of this
thing happening and it was right at the
beginning of the pandemic
through maybe a few weeks or a month
into the big uprisings last summer
um and i think that as i was
interviewing people later in the summer
and in the fall
and doing all my research you know kind
of the like sense that i was getting
people loved it they were like i get to
see all this music i get chat with my
friends
um some people don't drink they like
being
in spaces where they can see music
without drinking some people don't like
staying up late some people don't like
talking over the music i mean it was
just positive
and honestly i think there's a lot of
streaming still
happening and i think there's a lot of
streaming not happening i think as with
so many things during the pandemic
we started to burn out on a little bit
so i was
very bullish maybe like you know six
months ago when i was really thinking
about this stuff
thoroughly for the first time and these
days i don't know i mean i think that
it'll continue to some extent and i
think especially after
covet people will live stream shows
um that are happening in person because
it's you know a way to get extra people
to see it it's a good thing people like
it
um and i think the other thing that
we're going to continue to see is kind
of this trend towards
again tl i keep referring to you what tl
taylor describes in her book watch me
play which is
something similar to what video gamers
do where it's you know kind of like
individuals kind of spontaneously
hopping on the stream
it's a place their friends can hang out
they develop their own followings
i am not sure if we're going to continue
really seeing it's kind of like
community level
live streams as much um i think there
are places where it happens already so
the jam dance scene is an interesting
one
um in another version of the thesis i
would talk about fish who
uh you know they basically live stream
every single show on their tour and
people have made a big practice out of
getting together with their friends in
the same room to watch a live stream and
hang out
but also to kind of watch these live
streams and chat about them in other
ways
stuff like that might happen i mean it's
a little hard to say but one thing that
i do feel pretty confidently about
is in terms of the improvisation thing i
mean i didn't talk about it much here
but
i think especially with djs there's a
risk that all this
disappears from twitch kind of more or
less within the next year or the next
couple years if twitch decides to start
cracking down on ip
um which they're starting to do video
games and
you know i mean i guess the djing thing
is an interesting one because you know
the party ego ship where there was a
fire that was a dance party through djs
i'm talking about a situation where
people might get booted from twitch
because the nature of their art form is
that they're using
in theory copyright material right or if
it
fits whatever ip uh regime got used to
shut down naps and all that
so i don't really know and all i can
really say is i i hope
and i think there's a way to do it but i
hope that as we emerge
from this moment people realize that
it's community that helped keep music
together
and they really started to think about
what they can do to stabilize
communities because the
model has been running for a long time
of individual
careerism i don't think that's actually
what supports robust communities
um and safety and improvisation overall
sorry that was a long answer
thanks there's a um a question also in
in chat from eric gordon um thanks for
this wonderful talk you've given me a
lot to think about
i'm trying to understand how central
improvisation is to the formation of
community
is it the act of change or play that
provides the connective tissue
or the communicative capacity for
communities to form
um eric thank you for asking that play i
think that's a good question because i
think yeah absolutely there's always
like a
playfulness to people coming together
around music
right i mean no one's doing it because
they have a solemn duty to go to a show
or a party um
i have a hard time tracing causality
here
but what i can say is that i think
improvisation is a way of expressing
that community
and i think if you want to look at the
way people get together
living improvisation is a good way to do
it um you know so obviously things that
might form a community in a city could
be anything from
or around music could be anything from a
long tradition of that music in the city
to
frankly gentrification bringing in a lot
of people who find a cheap place to open
an art space
and then other people can use transit to
get there and it
actually undoes a lot of how it
contributes on doing a lot of
communities already in that neighborhood
right and in a way those might both be
in prosperity practices
um so i i have a hard time saying that
improvisation is the root of it but we
can kind of
think about how improvisation guides
things how it
expresses uh how these things form and
all of that
other questions
well i'll i'll just jump in there for a
second and
and just a to congratulate you on this
um as as a work of improvising in
in the face of rapid change as in in
addition to the to the work itself and
um i wanted to ask you about um
you know when you ask the question what
is community
you come back to an idea of of a kind of
collective care right um
a kind of structure of collective care
um and when
i think in some of our first
conversations we were
talking about specific music scenes
right and i'm thinking about how those
two are are not the same
right that that within specific music
scenes there are all
there there have always been
um ways in which that care is not
completely shared in in ways in which
communities
of care form within larger scenes
right and so i just wanted to ask you
you know if you could
reflect upon that that difference since
since those two are not
quite synonymous but you're talking
about certain kinds of communities
that arise within
larger kind of fandoms or scenes
yeah i think that's a a really good
point and i think um
you tapped into something important
which is that it's really hard to think
of the kind of care community
paradigm as something that exists
outside of other paradigms in music
which are kind of based more on an
economy or career or stuff like that
and oftentimes they exist in the same
genres in the same cities amongst the
same groups of people
kind of intention with each other um
and maybe the best way i could answer
that question is by talking something i
cut from the presentation which appears
in my pieces
which are all these stories i got from
queer people
um about situations where they were
excluded from
their local community scene either
outright because of discrimination
people
wouldn't book them which is kind of wild
because they were both dj's dance music
comes out of the black
gay chicago community in the 80s right
but on the other hand it's they also get
excluded by
fact of facing harassment when they go
to a club or when they go to
some show and you know you could say
okay maybe a bar
that's seeking to make money has a
little interest in
they're looking at harassment right um
even if they depend on a certain group
of people and kind of community to
frequent it for a certain
party but i think that you can look at
the kind of care component as something
that sometimes happens at those parties
because of people who
go to them and i think about when i
lived in chicago there was um
uh an effort to start collecting
um you know feminine hygiene products at
one of the night clubs to distribute
most the homeless population
but then there's also the situations
where people forced out
of those kinds of more commercial spaces
because of the things i was just talking
about start to form their own
care communities in kind of a diy sense
so i
was talking to someone who said look i
don't go to clubs as much anymore
i play them but i don't really enjoy it
because people always remark on my body
because i'm trans but
as a response to that i went and i
started a diy party and ran every week
for years and it was
a wonderful haven um
people like me and my friends and for
what it's worth i didn't even
realize that there was a club scene in
the city where this person was telling
me about i've only ever heard of that
diy party
in some sense when i think of that city
i think of that diy party
so there's a relationship there that i
don't know i guess you could call it
kind of like dialectic
um yeah but it's fascinating to think
about
um yeah
thanks um
and just any any other questions
out there
i think we may have come to the end of
the day
um let's uh let's give mike
a round of applause
um and this has
been a really really impressive
set of presentations today and and um
this is you know this day is why i love
cms
you know it's you see all of this come
together all this brilliance
originality um pushing the field
and i just want to congratulate all of
you who presented today
um and um thank all of you who came to
to participate and to to watch the
presentations
so again thank you thank you all and
we will see you all soon in one
one place or another